Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy. I'm
your host, David Flanagan.
Although you could find me across the Internet
as Rawkode.
Today, we're back for a new episode of
Rawkode live where we take a look at
the local development environment experience or at least
develop it locally against a Kubernetes cluster for
all of your Kubernetes cloud native software development
needs. That is a perpetually difficult problem to
solve. And today, we're taking a look at
a new ish solution called Mutter d.
To guide us on our journey to explore
this technology, we have
Avaram and I'll from the MetalBear Cool team.
Hi there. How are you doing?
Great.
Is it MetalBear Cool or just MetalBear? I
never know whether to call you by, like,
the Twitter handle or like where your company
name.
Metal bear was taken.
So
we had a A lot of people, a
lot of different people. So good stuff.
Nice. Well, before we dive into kinda what
matter is, can you both just take a
moment to introduce yourself, share a little bit
more about you, and then we'll kick things
off. Let's start with you in the middle,
Aviram.
Hi, everyone. I'm Aviram. I'm a middle of
the CEO and
maintainer.
My experience
is mostly security level,
but less experience was back in engineer. I
met in
last company
and where we faced a lot of issues
together in the back end side. And
that's what led us to build mirrord and
start.
Yeah. And and I'm. I'm a director
and CTO.
I'm I live in Tel Aviv. I have
a technical background that I won't bore you
with.
My dog here, but my feet is very
uneducated,
so please excuse any sharp yips.
And happy to be here.
Alright. Thank you both for joining us.
Alright. So
we've gotten a few hellos in the chat
and a comment about the audio. I'll look
into that in a second. Don't worry. And
we'll get it fixed in a moment.
Maybe we can start off then
by understanding
what mirrord is and the problem that is
trying to solve. Now I said this at
the start. Right? And I feel that this
is just one something that's always been difficult
in Kubernetes.
And I'm hoping what we're gonna look at
today, you're just gonna give me like the
golden path, the shining light that just makes
all of this easier. So let's
cover what is mother d and the problem
that addresses.
Yeah. So
in the easiest way to describe mirrordea is
the way to execute your local process service
in the cost context of the cloud environment.
And what it means is that mirrordea
plugs into your ID as an
a plug in that you can just enable,
disable, or comes a CLI, which you can
use to execute your services.
And once you enable mirrordea or execute the
process with mirrordea, what it does, it brings
you the environment level of your remote service.
It
lets you access the remote files without doing
any mounts, without copying, doing any changes of
your local machine. Everything is done in the
process level.
It lets you access the remote services.
So anything you have on the remote cluster
that is accessible to it, Kafka, Redis, any
any any network resource is available also to
you, including DNS.
And
for the fourth thing that it does, it
lets you get incoming traffic of the service.
So that comes in three modes. The first
one is enabling
so yeah. Yeah.
You asked me to say? Okay.
So and and
three modes of the incoming traffic is, a
a you can either mirror the incoming streams.
So any streaming coming to your remote service
is also duplicated to your local service, hence,
mirrord. Secondly,
you can steal traffic
of a specific port to your local to
your local service. Or the third option is
that you can steal HTTP traffic based on
headers or
API tests and HTTP filters in general.
And that's like the gist in a few
words.
Awesome.
Alright. I'm just gonna mute you for a
second to see if a bit of noise
goes away.
It did.
So the noise come to me?
Yeah. I think it's like
oh, I don't know. It's like when? I
don't know. It's like a weird
Is it windy where you are? Okay.
I
have air condition on.
Maybe it's better now. I'm using the camera.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. The microphone now.
Yes. That that the the AC noise has
now disappeared. That is amazing. Well done.
Well, so so I was understood. Like, I
I can repeat myself. I actually I jumped
into directly what it does instead of talking
about a problem, which is what I usually
do because I'm
Well, I think I could cover the the
problem. Like,
I have explored a lot of tools.
I've explored a lot of tools
at the Kubernetes space, you know, especially in
the development space. And a lot of them
all take the same approach to this developer
experience thing, right, which is
to
it's funny that the person that reported this
audio thing and that has now just given
us a thumbs up saying it's fixed. His
name is wind. So yeah.
Don't know why I found that funny.
But they they all take the same approach
to this problem of providing the developer experience.
Right? And that seems to be we're either
going to do some weird fail system mount
into a remote container, which we all know
is slow. Right? This is even slow in
Docker desktop for local development. Right? We can't
even build a PHP app under interpreted language
and sync the fails. That doesn't mean we
have to wait five seconds to refresh on
the web page. Right? And if we can't
do that, we can't do it over our
network.
And the other approach, which we've seen through
tools like scaffold as well, actually, let's just
build a container image locally because, you know,
that should be faster. But then we have
to sync the missing layers for that container
image to the remote cluster and get it
in some way. Like, they all make this
a very failed system centric problem.
And what I like about matter d is
that there's no
fail system problem. You've made a a networking
problem and you tackle this by doing magic
as far as I'm concerned with the way
that the packets are sent between the cluster
back to the user thing in a way
that gives them
not just a remote developer experience, but an
integrated developer experience where it allows them to
communicate and consume
work with cluster services and all of that.
I know my knowledge here is very fuzzy,
so I'm gonna need you to to jump
in and talk a bit more about why
you plan to own this approach and how
this actually works from the the magic in
network inside of things.
Yeah.
So
I think it it's it starts from the
experience that me and the other in the
last company,
and that's where the most valuable
process
step in the process we had is deploying
to staging.
So we had, like, a vast
data for each customer.
Everything very complex, and each customer, it was
a big enterprises.
And each customer, they own features and data,
and it involved AI
and ML.
So a lot of stuff needed to be
set up just to test the most basic
things.
So when you write write it unit
tests, integration tests, it never really
covers what you would see in production, what
you'd see in real life. And that's why
staging was the most valuable
environment because we had some of the traffic
duplicated into it so we could have real
data to interact with. And what happened
is that
we set up the very, very, very cool
stage environment where we can throw all the
versions at, but then we had a queue
where
each engineer needed to see that there's no
other engineers deploying the service. And each time
the service spend there, you didn't want them
to cross
cross contaminate
each other. And then you had the issue
of that, okay. You had an issue. You
need to hold for all back. So usually
happens in companies is that they just say,
okay. So staging needs to be stable.
So we need to do as many tests
as possible. So they do TDD. There are
tons of tests, and then they hit production
and still it doesn't work. Why? Because Azure
doesn't deploy the API version you expected. And
that's that's really sorry. Like, I had a
bug with Azure
Azure Blob Storage. It was a
specific version in our region wasn't deployed yet,
but the SDK had it. And so so
it worked locally because I used region, but
then when I plugged it to real environment,
it didn't work and it broke. Of course,
that's an issue also from the vendor side.
But, I mean, those those kind of mistakes
happen.
And what
and that led us to realize that we
want to enable developers
and engineers use staging as their development environment.
And
we started by just letting them get plugged
into staging so they can walk
continuously
against it. And as we develop more features,
we enable better concurrency walk in the staging
without breaking shutter. So that's, like, the general
flow of mind we had.
Okay.
What
like, this is one of these weird subjects.
Right? Like,
would you just let it feels to me
I could let people test and prod with
this tool. Right? And
at what point,
like, is that a sign of maturity of
your infrastructure if you could do this in
prod, or would you just always say always
do the staging? I I don't know. Like,
staging to me always just feels like an
a
Yeah. I think question because, you know, that's
that's sort of where we started. You know?
Or things like, why not do it in
prod?
Which it became very clear
very, very early that no one's gonna run
it in prod anytime soon. Like, you need
an established
product, and and
it's sort of a spectrum. You you got
prod, which is, of course, the best
replication of production. But then you've got staging,
which is, on one hand,
a good replication, but you're not as scared
of scared of trying tools on it, breaking
it, etcetera. And so, you know, that's where
we landed
for the initial stage. We are seeing a,
you know,
some organizations that are less afraid
of deploying things on production and so are
trying to to do it without our encouragement.
And,
yeah, and and we we are thinking of
it as a possible
future for mirrordies,
but we think that there is enough, you
know, meet in the staging for,
you know, for for the time being.
Yeah. I mean, I I don't wanna turn
in the listen to a political discussion about,
you know, testing and prod or whatnot.
But I've I've yet to see a good
staging environment that actually has,
you know, they're always very good from an
automation point of view and your production environment
really does look like a staging environment. And
this is just the people that I've seen.
I'm not saying this is all super nice
clusters in the world. But the path that
always falls down is when it comes to
data, the actual usage patterns within that cluster.
Now I have seen people that just take
a seven day old snapshot of production and
put it in station, and I think that's
a terrible idea as well. But
again, not not a topic of today's discussion.
But I do love that we could use
the traffic cloning
stuff within mirrord to inject
something into production, get real data without the
blast radius of that interception being
real
data.
We can get into that as we cover
the usage and take look at it in
more in more detail. I I I wanted
to add that in the first version of
PRD, where it is, it was just a
v s code extension very
early,
like, barely it was a barely walking MVP
that we just wanted to see how we
will react to it.
And when we posted it to hacking news,
we did a show h n. We we
we also put it in the marketing in
all the content that we said, mirror
production data and traffic into your local machine.
And all the people in hacking news were
like, no. Don't do that. So yes. Wait.
Because I didn't really know. The immediate typical
hacking news response that, oh, no. You you've
insane. Don't don't do that. So yeah. Well,
of course, you know, the risk appetite from
organize
to organization is always very different. And, you
know, hacker news,
I I don't think they're my people. There
is. So
I I am less risk averse. So we
we have a couple of notes and a
question I think in the comments just now
from when
so let's see. When they're saying that they
have an environment for end to end testing,
would this tool help developers to work when
they run their tests?
They're looking at this from the SRE perspective
where they don't have much dev and saves.
Yeah.
I just dropped it to that side. So
the answer is yes.
We see people running. You can run test.
You can run anything
that you can run. And we also see
companies
integrating mirrordine to the CI. So now you
have, like imagine you have your stable cluster,
and let's say you have all the stable
version of everything. So instead of doing a
blue blue green kind of redeployment into the
real environment, you just run the CI using
mirrordeep inside the staging cluster, and then you
get
partial
traffic just for your test to test it.
And once it's done, you can deploy it
to the real environment. So that's, like, another
use case we see. That's less than our
focus right now, but, like, mirroring is a
tool, so you can do whatever you want
with it. So and we see that happening.
Cool.
Alright.
So there was a diagram that we said
we were gonna talk about how matter do
you in fact, before we even get to
that, am I pronouncing that right? I know
that's, like, the tech question that everybody always
ask, but is it mirrord? Is it mirrord?
Is it something peculiar?
How do you see it?
It is it is mirrordy.
Tragically, a lot of people do think it's
mirrord, but,
yeah, it's the it's the tech pronunciation,
building its pronunciation.
Alright. And how would you spell that
cube command?
How do you pronounce that?
The the tool that you're using here. Yeah.
You mirrord.
Oh, no. No. It's alright. I'm just I'm
now just asking how you pronounce cube CTL.
Is it cube control, cube huddle? Ah, cube
CTL. Yeah.
Cube CTL.
Alright. Cool. I'll pick you in the SQL.
That's that's
the real it it in discussion.
Oh, I don't know if I'm on board
with SQL, but, again, I don't wanna turn
this into any sort of
pronunciation war.
Okay. So
I'm gonna pull up the website, then let's
dive into a little bit more about the
technical understanding of how this all works. So
here we have the mirrordea website if you
wanna check this out. It's available at mirrordea.dev.
And if we go back to the home
page,
there's a diagram at the bottom that tries
to talk about how this works.
Do you wanna go over this either of
you and talk about the networking stuff that's
going on within the cluster?
Yeah. Let's let's really quickly go over what
mirrordea does. Right? So mirrordea has two components,
the the layer or the client and the
agent.
And what happens when you run mirrordea is
that the layer is injected into the process,
and it overrides
low level function calls.
So, you know, file reads,
traffic,
outgoing traffic, etcetera.
And then it proxies them essentially
to to the cloud through the agent.
Right? So the agent, when when you run
mirrord is is is set up then. It's
it's a temporary agent. It cleans itself up
when you finish the execution,
and it runs adjacent to the pod that
you wanna impersonate.
And so the most basic flow to illustrate
this is a file read. Right? So if
you process, you're trying to read a file
locally,
mirrord would intercept that call and then pass
that to the agent, and the agent would
read the file from the pod instead. Right?
But we do the same thing for traffic
and for environment variables,
and that's how we achieve sort of a
hermetic
wrapping of your local process to, you know,
make it think that it's running remotely even
though the code is actually running
on your local machine.
Okay. So it's just like an LD preload
syscall hijacking within the pods.
Okay.
So
mean Not within the pods.
Wait. The the the
injection happens locally.
On the remote side, we don't do we
don't touch the real process. We just enter
the Linux namespaces of it so we can
access the same resources,
but we don't touch the remote process unless
you do a pause and then we pause
the process. But it's more of a advanced
feature.
Okay.
And I guess you aren't gonna do in
fail syncing, but it's very selective based on
the read Cisco. Right? I mean Yeah. So
so so the fail, it's still I mean,
it's not syncing the whole fail system, but
you are literally transporting the base off that
fail. Right?
Yeah. But, usually, what happens is that the
file reads are usually for secrets,
mounts, like, yeah, they're not usually, they don't
really they don't really read the data unless
there's, like, maybe
some
static database. But I I don't think we
have seen that use case very often. And
and and then
another thing that's very cool is that everything
is configurable. So you can say this regex
access it locally, this regex access it remotely,
and then you can mix and match. So
if there's a big file, you can just
make it pretty locally so you wouldn't you
wouldn't wouldn't have any latency there.
Cool.
I think it's time to jump into our
live section. Actually, just to show this working
so that the audience can get a feel
for what the process looks like to actually
build and develop
using Mutter d as their tool.
So to do that, I believe Avram is
going to guide us through a demo.
Yes. Absolutely. You're happy to do that now?
Yeah. Happy to do it always. That's like
a yeah. He's always joking that I'm like,
oh, you want I'm always offering people to
see a demo, and he's like, stop offering
people demo.
Alright. Well, if you're good at we're good
we've got one more know it's appropriate.
Right, Dale?
Yeah. So just to put it in a
context, so in our demo, we set up
a very by the way, you can see
my screen. Right? Yeah.
But do you mind if I throw a
couple of questions from the chat at you
first before we dive into that? Sorry. Sure.
Alright. So we've got one back, and one
was asking, is the partial traffic just splitting
on entry to the pod or container?
Yeah. So does
that's configurable.
So the default the default configuration would be
mirroring. So
it's not splitting. It's just you got the
same stream as the remote part. But if
you are hijacking the traffic, we call it
stealing,
that would
yeah. We split it. And then based on
the filters or based on just the the
port being stolen as well, and we plan
to have more capability on on top of
it based on the requirements from the users.
Okay.
And in true Russell fashion, who's the regular
on this channel, there's always a funny comment
followed by a real question. So apparently,
SQL is pronounced squirrel.
I haven't heard that before, but, you know,
feel free.
Now the question is, does mother do you
work with multiple users at the same time?
Does it separate the hijacking
of two devs, a and b, use mother
d with dev a hat mother with dev
a hat dev b's service?
Yeah. So
so
so it depends on the exact configuration. Like,
if you do mirroring, then you both will
get a mirror probably, and that would probably
work.
But that's what we call mirrordial that's why
we build what we call mirrordial teams,
which is a control plane for mirrordial. And
what it enables you to do is really
work concurrently multiple users on the same service
exactly. So if you and I work on
the same cluster, but each of one of
us works on a different service, then we
wouldn't have conflicts.
But if we want to work on the
same service, then the mirrordial teams
enables you to have multiple sessions on the
same target at the same time by giving
you synchronization primitives and also
making sure that you don't override each other.
Alright. Awesome.
Wendy also says thank you for that answer.
So I won't interrupt you anymore. Please feel
free to carry on with your demo.
Yeah. Feel free to disrupt me. I like
disruptions.
So yeah. So and, by the way, if
if we do help to clear this up,
but this is our setup. It's it's supposed
to be quite,
like, cover
very common use cases, but be very small.
So bear with me.
So
the cloud in our case is me, the
client. I can access IP visit counter, which
implements one API called count.
And what count does, it
takes my IP
and then
calls another service called IP info that provides
information about that IP.
It saves the IP to Redis in order
to store the the amount of the the
count of how many times I've seen this
IP. And it also sends the IP to
a Kafka
topic,
which an another service
cons consumes
and just prints the messages it gets from
them. So that's the setup.
Many questions, David? Does it make sense?
Nope. Makes sense.
Awesome.
So, David, what do you prefer? IntelliJ or
Versus Code?
I have a very strict rule, and I
have no JVM installed on any of my
machines. So,
yeah, I guess, PS code wins.
I thought you weren't doing politics.
I I I mean, it's tech. Everything's politics.
Right? But I
I I mean,
no. I can't do it. I can't run
the GVM. Sorry.
Yeah. I can blame you. Yeah. So we'll
use this code for example. Let me find
my window.
We also accept NeoVem, Vem, or Helix. All
acceptable answers.
Yeah.
Why do you do you use, Yael?
I'm I'm Versus Code. I was just trying
to rile rile up a conflict with Versus
Code. I mean, I've gotta say, like Versus
Code, language server supports. I mean, it's just
a and it it's still quite fast even
though it's an electron based application. I've gotta
say, they got a lot of things right.
It's a pleasant experience.
Okay. So you can see on Intel. Sorry.
Go ahead, everyone.
Yeah.
So you can see my screen now. Alright?
We could see your Versus code. Yep. You
got a terminal at the bottom. You got
some code above it. Yes.
Yeah.
I zoomed in. I did you know? And,
like, if the zoom is okay, you see
good enough?
And one more with her. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I think that's good there.
Awesome.
So
so this is our cluster. It has
nothing that is not the service that we
talked about. So we have the IP info
service, IP info cons consumer, and a IP
business counter.
I need to restart the consumer because
it dies. I didn't do any option there.
That's like I'm not a very proficient goer.
I just like that. We did a very
fast Wow. A rule out restart instead of
just deleting all the pods. That's classy.
Yeah.
So this
is our cluster.
So we have all the services here, and
we'll start by just showing
like this.
The API, what it does. So this is
on the remote. You can also like, other
people on the stream watching us, you can
also access it and see it for yourself.
This is all
new.
And you can see the account increasing
each time I have the request. Now I
want to start working on it. So
this is the service. This is the actual
code. It's a very complex code that does
this magic.
And we'll start by putting a breakpoint on
domain just to show how it starts working.
And when we install mirrord, that's what we
get. We get a little
I'm not sure how you call it. Like,
label
button I don't know. Menu menu, which you
can click. And once I click it, it
enables.
So this haven't done anything. This just, like,
toggle the
usage of. And the next time I run
my service, it would use mirroring.
And this
this one would use a configuration
that I will show in one sec. So
I can I can use it without any
configuration?
But just for the sake of this demonstration,
I would I would use this configuration.
It's not supposed to be here.
So what I put in the configuration is
target. Maybe I'll remove that to show you
how it works for, like, Moscow,
more common scenario.
And
yeah. So this is configuration.
We still and we'll send traffic only that
has this header,
and we'll re reload more files. We'll have
outgoing traffic, and this is pretty much default.
This is the only custom thing that was
done in this configuration.
Yeah. So now I can just go do
my
code, click
debug.
Oh, don't update now.
Sorry.
We had a new version, and I haven't
done it yet. So, hopefully, it won't break
anything.
We're back to testing them prod again. It's
okay. Yeah.
So can I just clarify a few things?
This is a mirrordy Versus code extension.
And just by being in this main dot
goal for the IP visit counter,
the majority extension has this JSON file loaded
and
knows how to replace that service or how
to intercept the traffic for that service within
the cluster.
Yeah. So the
the configuration file isn't required. Like, it what
what we do is pretty
much everything is very
self configured and very opinionated.
So
you don't need to configure, like, what,
like, what what I show right now. So
I removed the target, so now it will
let me choose. So now
I run it, and now I can choose
which target I want to mirror.
So I'm running the service,
so I will mirror that.
And then it does this is when we
spawn the agent, and now it's ready.
And now we see the service running, and
the breakpoint is hit. And you can notice
that this so the the process, everything is
running locally, the service itself.
So now we've hit the load config breakpoint.
We'll step into that.
And what we do is pretty much very
common thing. We load settings from the environment
So
I can just go over that, and then
let's inspect the config. We can see that
we got some information from it. That's not
for my environment. That's what's obtained from the
remote service.
And now
what's a very common thing we do is
we read
file for secrets and stuff. So in this
case, we have this path we want to
read. This path doesn't exist on my machine.
Either it's mounted, there is no remote. It's
no. It's running locally. That's what part of
the magical community.
So we get here. And
now we can see that it was loaded.
And the loading happened from the remote part,
so we actually got the remote file. If
you have any secret, any
anything that comes from the remote pod,
you immediately
add it because you have the and
you have the.
So now it goes through connecting to all
sort of stuff, and we just skip that.
And we have the service running now,
and you can see it's running on port
80, which is the same port the real
service is running on.
Now I can do curl,
and you see that nothing happened.
Why nothing happened is because
I've put in my configuration file,
not this configuration file.
This configuration file, because I want to still
traffic only with this header.
So now I will place this header, and
the breakpoint is hit. And you can see
also the request is being installed.
Why is it stopped? Because it's me holding
the request, and I didn't need to respond.
So I just let it go,
and you can see the response coming in.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Any questions so far?
No. That makes a lot more sense just
in that one little demo.
You know, I was thinking about it completely
the wrong way when I was talking about,
you know, the rates,
you know, during the interception and the part.
But, of course, it's it's just all running
locally, and it's to make sure that when
I wanna consume Kubernetes secrets or even environment
variables for several discovery,
any of this stuff that it works even
though we're running everything
locally.
But, yeah, just like a late bulb opens.
Oh, yeah. Of course. That's of course, it
makes total sense. I was just being a
bit bit a bit tough, but, you know,
hopefully, I had two coffees to taste, so
that's okay.
Yeah. So that that really helped. That
yeah. Good. Yeah. I think I think one
of one of the things we we see
come on with people is that when we
experiment with mirrordea, like, verbally and also from
documentation, they don't really get a grasp. Like,
they imagine a lot of,
like, people promise thirty seconds and very quick
and magic, and, like, they don't expect that.
Right? And and when they actually see a
demo from Unity,
they say, oh, this is actually different than
what we've seen in other in other things.
So,
yeah, I think a demo a demo also
of of
really heads.
Yeah. So this is the more simple
example.
And now we can go into a bit
more deeper
example. So what we do in the request
so I said it sends a request to
the upstream service.
And the upstream service,
we propagate
headers,
which is very use common. You can also
use observability headers that usually propagate to web,
like, it's race saving.
And you can use that also to
steal traffic based on that. And then
when we do that,
we go to the other service, which is
the upstream service.
And I will also steer on the based
on the same header filter.
So
now let's go to the code ID info
wait. It contains something I didn't want to
show. One second.
I don't see that.
So this is my code, and now I
will run it.
And if you notice, the info which returned
was.
And now this version that I have locally
is LovesAAA,
which is you a A is an acronym
for,
I don't know, something.
So DNAForAPV6.
Right?
Yeah.
Yeah. So now I can
you can see that the real service is
answering. And when I do the header,
it propagates and then gets to me. So
now I can still let service inside the
cluster that isn't even in being ingressed
and exposed externally.
I mean, now we can see the response.
It's also for my local service.
Yeah. And that's, like, the very basic
demo demo.
Yeah. I think
we can
stop it here
for now. Like, we go we can go,
like, more interactive. But
Yeah. So
the so this call so this is working
with it. If I tried to read from
the environment, it's intercepted. If I wanna read
from a fail, it's intercepted. If I make
a DNS resolution or network request, I'm assuming
that gives intercepted and handled appropriately too. And,
I mean, not really that relevant maybe to
the audience, but I'm just curious because I
work in a lot of Kubernetes,
like, controllers and operators.
If I wanna hook into the Kubernetes API,
use the service account, get a lease and
stuff like that, that would all just work.
Yeah. So funny story. So we said we
developed mirrordial teams. Mirrordial teams is an operator.
So we dug for the lot. So
and and the operator wants to the cluster,
and then the operator of mirrordial, the sponsor
instance of mirrordial.
We debug it using mirrordial.
So, if this works and not releases and
everything, we actually had a very, tough bug,
where,
I can't remember what exactly happened.
What happened?
Yeah. Okay. So funny story. So we I
debugged the operator,
and then
I saw that it access it's accessing the
external IP of the Kube API because it
uses the Kube API. And I didn't understand
why. And then what
I found out is that the
we use Kubernetes, which is great great for
developing
Kubernetes APIs in Rust.
And
the the the first thing it does, it
looks up for a cube config.
And we exclude it by default stuffs that
come from slash users because that's usually stuff
you want to be obtained locally.
We have a lot of defaults to make
a very seamless experience. So it actually used
my local cube config file instead of using
the environment variables of the remote
of the remote cluster. So I I was
like it took me, like, two days to
realize
that was going on. It was tough. But
yeah. And and now we are explicit.
Use only classic.
So yeah.
Nice. I think that's the first time I've
mentioned Rust, which I'm actually surprised about because
normally, like, that's the first thing I try
and say in every stream. But it is
all written in Rust. Right?
Yeah.
Everything that's not extensions,
which we have to conform to the SDKs
of the vendors.
Yeah.
Everything is rust. Yeah. I really like Kubernetes.
It's a very cool project.
Yeah. We do have some Unmaintained also.
Sorry?
Well maintained also. Like Oh, yeah. Yes. We
we
send a lot of stuff out to him,
and he's very responsive and very friendly. Really
appreciate him.
Yeah.
Alright. We've got some questions. So let's let's
start with the one from.
If my local process runs on Port 80
and the service is on Port 88, can
I matter eighty eighty to remote Port 8
locally?
So do you have do you have any
control over the the way the ports work?
Yeah. So maybe I'll share my screen for
that because think we're gonna one too. Yeah.
So
like we said, we we really like having
like, we we desire the user experience to
be that you can just plug it in
and and it works for you. But as
you want the more advanced configuration, we have
tons of configuration for you. So
in this case, we're talking about the incoming
traffic. So we have here port mapping. And
port mapping, you can say exactly that. It's
also auto completed to,
yeah, the same map
and mapping. So that this says that, okay.
Locally, I listen on 80, but remotely, I
want to steal or mirror
eighty eighty.
Okay. And does this just use whatever cube
context I'm on? I'm assuming you're not having
to provide any other information. I'm just making
sure that your current session is using the
right or you can also point to a
second. Okay.
But it gives us the other local one.
Yeah. We use the default API of QRS,
which does
you have a cube config end, which also
cube context should set.
So, basically, yes, it should work quite quite
seamlessly with the Kubernetes experience of your local
machine.
And can I set the context if I
have a KubeConfig with multiple context,
or would I have to switch locally first?
Yeah. You you need to switch it locally
first. Yeah. I think that's probably expected, so
no big deal.
Alright. Russell asked,
sorry. I think I missed it. Are the
files red just in time? So when a
syscall is executed, or do you do any
scanning parsing to pull them at the start
of the session?
You can answer it now.
Yeah. Yeah. I think we've seen that through
the the breakpoints. Yeah. So
Yeah. I actually saw that Mugul from our
team answered in the chat. But just to
reiterate, the the read just in time.
We hope the file reads.
And so when I when your process tries
to read the file, that's when we pass
it to the agent. Agent reads the file,
pass it back to you.
Okay.
Alright. Went says awesome. We will test this
in our environment. It's good to see. Russell
has been in your documentation
and sees that it had sent to the
epsies who works with first spells tool.
I mean, I'm assuming it worked with with
most applications. Is that a fair assumption? Are
there any gotchas that people should be aware
of?
Yeah.
It works with most applications, like, applications that
I would say love people.
And, like, yeah, the exclusion would be Go
on Linux that tries to
go to direct Cisco, and then we directly
hook the Cisco
calls of Go. So that's what Russell meant.
Like, we put specific we we have a
specific
stream or customization to work with Go. Currently,
we work with Go only on
x 64, which is the common processor,
and we need to add
the same for
ARM,
but we haven't gone there yet. Usually,
people just prefer to run it locally. So
on macOS,
they can't use a directical Cisco because
Apple doesn't provide stable internal API. So that's
nice. Thank you, Apple.
Yeah. Working on a Mac just gets easier
and easier. Right? Anyway,
let's talk about, like,
you know, let's say I I just
I wanna make my life easier for developers
and my team. I think matter is easy
answer.
No. Do I just start going to all
of my projects, all of my repositories and
adding the matter d dot JSON?
Do I put make fail targets in where
people can just run
the matter d CLI? Like, how do people
get started? What's the preferred way? What's the
most what's the lowest friction way for teams
to start adopting us across all of their
services?
So
Let me prefix that. Right? Because there's a
bit of context in my head that I've
not really verbalized.
And what I was saying really is that
that's better data JSON. Does it just work
with the Versus code extension? Does it work
with the CLI? What's the preferred approach for
teams moving forward?
Yeah.
So,
basically, what the
extensions do is they use the CLI. So
everything works with a config file. So everything
that you can do in the extension, you
can do in the CLI.
The extensions are just, like, giving better use
experience and better
settings when it comes running from ID.
In public, what we see people sometimes, they
execute via the CLI using make files, using
trust files, using
Bazel, and then they
use the ID to yeah.
They use it to we just had someone
in the discordash in.
I not the first one. It's, like, the
third people a person that they asked about
it.
And then they launch it using immunity,
and then they attach the debugger, for example,
using the IDK. That's
less of how we see it being used,
but, of course, anyone can adopt it in
any way they can they want.
Yeah. So so when it comes to adoption,
so I think one of the advantages, like,
compared to other alternatives, is that you don't
have to install it for everyone. You can
like, I'm I'd be around my IC, mirroring.
I can just get started, and that's also
what we see. We see people getting started.
Initially, use it for the specific use case.
Like, I would say, one of the first
use cases they
that comes to their mind is that they
want to debug. Right? That's an ability we
lost as back end engineers.
Like, oh, we just add logs at the
tracing and deploy. And, like, in the best
case, you know, we can attach a debugger
to the remote environment,
but, like, it it's not very comfortable.
And, like, the first thing they use mirrordial
is for actually debugging using the ID.
And then as they use it more
from and as they use mirroring more and
they gain
and they get more confident with it, they
realize they can just use it for developing
on a daily on a continuous basis. So
now I can just each
change of code I do can just run
it in a few minutes in a remote
environment, see that it works, and then write
the test. So instead of, like, thinking about
all the scenarios I'm gonna meet, what kind
of database, what data in the database, what
what's the relation? Can just plug it in,
see what happens. Okay. This works. Okay. Let's
write a test that's covered. Cover more,
let's say, mild
mild cases, but not like the extreme edge
cases to cover everything so it would work
in any case.
And,
yeah, I would say that's, like, usually
the road.
Okay. Let's dive into this config a little
bit deeper then. So right here, we have
an HTTP filter.
We're doing a header filter. We're looking for
the PG tenant as other. Is there any
interpolation on this file? Can I use an
environment variable to put in my username
just to pull out certain things? And I'm
thinking this is on a get repository. It's
shared with the entire team.
Can we inject something in there?
Yeah. Actually, that's a good idea. We haven't
thought about it yet.
But, yeah, in interpolating
settings, like, the team is also on the
chat, so that's
great initiative.
But
so right now, it's static. Like, you can
commit it, but you can it it's not
something you can
reinterpret or extrapolate
for all of that matters,
unfortunately.
But I I that's a good idea.
Okay. And are there any other
l seven aware failures beyond HTTP? Does it
understand gRPC,
Kafka?
What else's options are?
Yeah.
So when we talk about like, we divide
it into two categories, like, you have incoming
and you have outgoing. So, you know, Kafka,
you pull. We don't consider it incoming. We
talk about the network stack. Like, is it
an outgoing connection? Is it an incoming connection?
So on the outgoing level,
which applies to Kafka, we don't do anything
special. We just let you connect to remote
service. We do plan to have more, like,
filters and
and smart
application level protocol
features.
But right now, it's just, like, plain connection.
So anything you can connect to, you can
connect to from to the remote service.
And in terms of the incoming,
right now, we support
h t p one, two,
and that covers gRPC.
So as far as we know,
gRPC
is over HTTP usually, HTTP two. And the
headers of the metadata
of a gRPC,
the back of the thing goes into HTTP.
So you can also use the HTTP
primitives
to filter and work with gRPC. So
Are there any problems with TLS to interfere
with this, or does it just work out
of the box?
Yeah.
So in
let's say, the best practice
when you use
MTLS,
in cluster TLS,
usually have a sidecar. The application doesn't do
TLS. I I hope for I mean, like,
unless you do an operator.
The t TLS is done on a sidecar.
And, also, in the an operator, actually, you
can do a cycle. But, usually, it's a
site code. And then because MewD enters the
Linux name of the real process, we just
get the plain traffic.
So once TLS termination happens at the same
card, then the local traffic is unencrypted, then
it just it should just work that way.
Yeah.
But if you use TLS,
you can't
use the the HTTP filters. You can just
steer the port, and then you terminate it
locally. So that would work. Like, that's how
we develop with the operators, for example.
K.
I think last
question from me right now. So if anyone
watching has anything they wanna ask before we
finish up, please feel free to drop it
into the comment section.
But I
looking oh, yeah. I was just doing basically
I'm looking at your config, but it disappeared.
But it doesn't matter. I was looking at
your conflict and you're targeting a deployment called
IP info. Think it was. Does that inject
the
oh, does that work for all the pods
and the deployment? Is it just a specific
one? How I mean, it doesn't even matter.
I'm not sure. Like, how does that work?
Yeah.
So in the open source version, what it
does in the when you specify deployment, you
just choose a random pod. Like, the first
one it encounters,
which means random.
In the operator, it enables you to really
work on deployment. So now instead of stealing
from one pod, you can steal from the
all of replicas of the same deployment.
Yes. So it's a good question.
Okay. Awesome.
Alright. I'm not sure if Dimitri is on
your team or not. But Dimitri has commented
saying that some things can be overwritten by
environment variables, but not all.
Is Dimitri on your team or just a
random helper? Yeah.
Yeah.
Alright.
Perfect. Alright. We got a question from why
I'm all who messed up again.
Shame. I guess you could always watch back.
It's on YouTube. But the question was, can
I matter to an app running on my
host?
Would be perfect for the build to pricing
cycle.
Yes.
Exactly. That that's what we really does.
And we agree. It's perfect.
Yeah. Good. Just jump back to the start.
Check it out. The demo was cool. I
hope it helps.
Question from Russell. When you steal traffic, can
you steal a subset traffic with a certain
header set?
I think that's what we showed. Right?
Yeah. So we showed that. You can still
base on header filtering.
You can still base on path, and we're
happy to add any more filtering
conditions
that users want. Okay? Just request it.
Alright. Thank you from why I'm all I
guess we confirmed exactly what they needed to
hear. Alright.
Let's talk about the future then. I think
we've covered the problem pretty well. I think
we've seen there's a really good solution, the
integration with Versus Code. Any of those intelligent
people out there. I'm sure it's just as
good, but
we now have a tool chain that allows
us to develop a a pretty strong developer
experience.
And what's coming in the future? You've met
mentioned matter of data for Teams. Maybe you
can talk about more of it there and
maybe what else is what what's on your
road map or agenda for the open source
plan as well?
Yeah.
So
there is mostly to enhance the experience of
mirrordial, like, cover more use cases and become,
like so right now, start mirroring. And when
we try to to start from the very
primitive, like, we really like going very lean
and see what users react to best. That's
what we did from the start and what's
we what we want to keep doing. We
do have, like, a a more,
like, broad road map, but, essentially, that's what
we do. But in terms of
of what we want to do, so so
so the longer term vision is that community
starts with a very
intuitive and naive way. So just steers traffic
and just redirects traffic to the cluster. Seems
easy, but it provides a better user experience
than any other solution
you would have. But as we develop it,
we had HTTP header filter. We're gonna have
application filters for the outgoing traffic. So now
you can duplicate the Kafka messages. You can
provide the best way to work on the
remote environment without
while controlling
that your effect on it. So
that is to make mirrord the
tool you can use daily,
and
enables you,
let's say, the best
way of isolating yourself while developing while not
really spinning up the whole environment. So we
get the best of both worlds. You get
a real mature remote environment
while, you're able to control and not
contaminate it.
K.
Alright. Let's gonna ask the question that's been
on my head for the last fifty three
minutes now.
Why is there a GitHub, like, behind you
and not a mail there?
I wanna see one of those lights in
the mail there.
Sorry. What's the question? I didn't get it.
You've got a GitHub lamp behind you. Right?
The neon sign? I
mean, I'm looking at the middle there.
Neon sign.
Yeah.
He didn't get a free neon sign from
metal there, only from GitHub. So Oh, you
need to make that happen for the next
time we have an episode. I'll take that.
Yeah. LED sign. We'll go. We just have
shots right now.
Let's see it. One second. Yeah. There we
go. The full thing. Nice. Very cool.
Like it. Way, Al is the
creative
director of.
All the ideas of design that's where it
come from is steam in hell.
I'm like, oh, no. It's just I
do outsource, so I know the audience. So
Yeah. I look into brand enhancement,
but it doesn't do actual design. It's it's
better than, like, it's on my level. So
Yeah. I mean, I do a lot of
front end design, but I go I go
as far as black text in my background.
That's as good as I can get with
CSS.
Same.
Alright.
Where can people learn more? Do you have
a Discord, a Slack community, a Discourse? How
can people get involved?
You know, do you have PRs?
Welcome. Issues, easy, get started, all labels. Like,
tell people how they can help you out
with with what you're doing at mirrordea. So
we have a
disco channel.
We like to see it as a back
end engineers community. So it's like you have
mirroring channels and you have general channels. You
can use any of those. Like, if you
use mirroring, you can ask questions for support
or maybe
get mentored for a PR.
And, yeah, we welcome PRs to all of
our repositories. Like, there's big open issues. We
try to level those.
So if you want to hit an issue,
let us know. Happy to jump on this
call, explain it further,
help you
get started, help you
get into Rust, get into Kubernetes, this kind
of stuff.
I'm not sure if it's the first project
to get into Rust, to be honest, because,
like, we have maybe at some point that
are simple.
But, like, if you want to do advanced
Rust,
I would say that's a very good project
to look at it.
Yeah. So happy to see all of you
in Discord,
and feel free to reach out Discord, GitHub.
I don't know. Any means of communication
that is not, like, coming to my front
door. Like, you can come in to my
front door, but, like, invite them. So Awesome.
Well, I encourage people to join the Discord.
Check out the project.
If you enjoy it, you run into any
problems, open issues, comment on this video, and
we'll do your best to get you some
help.
We have one question as snuck in right
at the end there. So we'll answer that,
and then we'll wrap up for today. But
YMO asks,
there is Go code in the repository. Does
that mean that you have an SDK and
Go people can embed?
So
that's a great question, actually, because we don't
have any SDK. You just run your process
using Unity.
I didn't show that, but you can run
curl using Unity. Like, we had a user
saying that
that
used to upload configuration into the cluster. I
assume that was, like, a XTP or something
like that. And it just just kill to
post that request into the XTP.
So you can run everything
on your machine. So go comparison to a
binary, and then we run it using. So
anything that is a binary, can use mirroring
with. No SDK. No integration needed to do
from your side. Just plug it into your
ID and start working on it.
Awesome. Thank you for that. Alright. We'll finish
with Russell's comment saying thank you for the
demo. Matter of the looks like the future
of developing in Kubernetes. I don't think I
can see anything better than that. So we'll
wrap up. And thank you both for joining
me and for sharing your knowledge and everything
that we've learned about Matter of the
is there any final words before we finish
up?
Wait. We show pets? I I can I
can bring Jimmy in? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Right.
Jimmy.
Jimmy. He
was crying. So
This is Jimmy.
He's a little demon.
He wants to Yeah. Anyone joining Middlebury gets
a free yeah.
A free dog?
Free dog. Yeah. Did we not mention that?
Alright,
I'll send my CV right after this call.
Yeah. Yeah.
Alright. Any more pets to be shown? You
got one there?
Yeah. It's serious. It's haunted.
And then all that.
I don't I don't have mine in my
office. My my pets are all at home,
but next time, for sure, I'll bring some
in for the day.
Alright. Well, thank you again. It's been an
absolute pleasure. And I really love what are
doing. I hope everyone else enjoys this demo,
and we'll see you all soon. Have a
good day.
Awesome. Thank you. Bye, everyone.